No one goes to Hank's for his spreadsheets. They go for a darn good pizza. Lately, though, the shop's been quiet. So Hank decides to bring back the $1 slice. He asks Copilot in Microsoft Excel to look at his sales and costs. Help him see if he can afford it. Co-pilot shows Hank where the money's going and which little extras make the dollar slice work.
没人会为了汉克的电子表格而去他的店里，他们去那里是为了吃上一顿美味的披萨。但最近，店里变得冷清了。于是汉克决定重新推出1美元一片的披萨。他请微软Excel中的Copilot查看他的销售额和成本，帮他看看自己是否负担得起。Copilot向汉克展示了资金的去向，以及哪些小细节能让1美元披萨的方案行得通。
Now, Hank has a line out the door. Hank makes the pizza. Co-Pilot handles the spreadsheets. Learn more at M365Copilot.com slash work. What does it mean to be an extremist? The word might call up images of political violence or terrorism, but extreme behaviors are all around us and can be a force for good as well as destruction. Extreme single-mindedness and focus can spur scientists to make new discoveries and artists to create great art. Today we're going to talk to two psychologists about the psychology of the extreme.
现在，汉克的店门口排起了长队。汉克负责做披萨，Copilot负责处理电子表格。欲了解更多信息，请访问M365Copilot.com/work。什么是极端主义？这个词可能会让人联想到政治暴力或恐怖主义的画面，但极端行为在我们周围随处可见，它既可以是一种破坏力量，也可以是一种向善的力量。极端的专注和一心一意可以激励科学家做出新的发现，也可以激励艺术家创作出伟大的艺术作品。今天，我们将与两位心理学家探讨极端心理学。
What drives people to extreme behaviors, both constructive and and destructive? Is there an extremist personality? And if so, is it something you're born with? Is there a connection between extremism and mental illness? How does social media drive extremism? Is the world becoming more extreme? And can psychological research on extremism suggest ways to reach people at risk of turning violent or harming others? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
是什么驱使人们产生建设性或破坏性的极端行为？是否存在“极端主义人格”？如果有，这是天生的吗？极端主义与精神疾病之间有联系吗？社交媒体如何助长极端主义？世界是否正变得越来越极端？关于极端主义的心理学研究能否为接触那些有暴力倾向或伤害他人风险的人提供方法？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。
I have two guests today. First is Dr. Ari Kruglanski, a distinguished professor of psychology at the University of Maryland and a founding co-director and co-principal investigator of NC Start, the National Center for the Study of Terrorism and the Response to Terrorism. His research interests include violent extremism, political activism, the quest for significance and closed-mindedness. Dr. Kuglansky is the author of more than 400 academic articles, chapters, and books.
今天我有两位嘉宾。第一位是马里兰大学心理学杰出教授阿里·克鲁格兰斯基博士，他也是NC Start（国家恐怖主义研究与应对恐怖主义中心）的创始联合主任和联合首席研究员。他的研究兴趣包括暴力极端主义、政治激进主义、对意义的追求以及封闭心态。克鲁格兰斯基博士撰写了400多篇学术文章、章节和书籍。
He has won many awards for his work, including APA's 2025 Award, for Distinguished Scientific Contributions. Next is Dr. Sophia Moskalenko, a research fellow at Georgia State University and a program management specialist at the UN Office of Counterterrorism Behavioral Insights Hub. She's a social and clinical psychologist who studies extremism, terrorism, and radicalization, and was previously a researcher at NC Start. Dr. Moskalenko and Dr. Kuglansky are co-authors of a new book called The Psychology of the Extreme, which was published in February.
他因其工作获得了许多奖项，包括美国心理学会2025年杰出科学贡献奖。下一位是佐治亚州立大学研究员、联合国反恐办公室行为洞察中心项目管理专家索菲亚·莫斯卡连科博士。她是一位社会和临床心理学家，研究极端主义、恐怖主义和激进主义，此前曾是NC Start的研究员。莫斯卡连科博士和克鲁格兰斯基博士合著了一本名为《极端心理学》的新书，该书于二月出版。
Thank you both for joining me. Pleased to be here. Thank you for having us. For both of you, much of your work has focused on political extremism and violence, but in your new book, you talk about extremism, more broadly. So let me ask you, how do you define extremism? Extremism is a psychological state of motivational imbalance. That happens when one of our basic needs is so dominant that it crowds out the others. And when that happens, the constraints that those
感谢两位参加我的节目。很高兴来到这里。谢谢你们的邀请。对你们两位来说，你们的大部分工作都集中在政治极端主义和暴力上，但在你们的新书中，你们更广泛地谈到了极端主义。那么请问，你们如何定义极端主义？极端主义是一种动机失衡的心理状态。当我们的某种基本需求占据绝对主导地位，以至于排挤了其他需求时，这种情况就会发生。而当这种情况发生时，那些其他需求通常对行为施加的约束就会放松，甚至完全消失。
other needs normally impose on behavior are relaxed, if not completely removed. And when that happens, anything that serves the dominant need is legitimized, is permitted, including things that would otherwise be constrained by alternative considerations. So take, for example, hunger. When we are moderately hungry, our eating behavior is constrained by considerations of health, of taste, of social norms, of what people in our society consider as legitimate for consumption. But when the hunger becomes extreme, all those constraints fade away and anything is legitimized for consumption, including bark of the trees, your pets, even bodies of other human beings, as was demonstrated in this unfortunate, tragic,
当这种情况发生时，任何服务于主导需求的事物都会被合法化、被允许，包括那些在其他情况下会受到替代性考量约束的事物。以饥饿为例。当我们适度饥饿时，我们的进食行为会受到健康、口味、社会规范以及我们社会中人们认为合法的消费方式的约束。但当饥饿变得极端时，所有这些约束都会消失，任何东西都会被合法化用于消费，包括树皮、宠物，甚至是其他人类的尸体，正如安第斯山脉那场不幸的悲剧中所展示的那样，
event in the Andes when the plane crashed and the survivors were forced to eat their fallen comrades' flesh. So this paradigm of removal of constraints is something that applies to extremism across the board. So for example, when the need for significance and metering is the predominant need, considerations of life, family, career, social norms fade away, and you would do anything. You would kill and die in order to satisfy that need. And that's, you know, the paradigmatic instance of extremism, this motivational imbalance, this one-track mind that legitimize anything that serves that dominant need.
当时飞机坠毁，幸存者被迫吃掉已故同伴的肉。因此，这种消除约束的范式适用于各行各业的极端主义。例如，当对意义和重要性的需求成为主导需求时，对生命、家庭、事业、社会规范的考量就会消失，你会做任何事。为了满足这种需求，你会杀人，也会去死。这就是极端主义的典型例子，这种动机失衡，这种只认准一个目标的思维，使任何服务于该主导需求的行为都变得合法。
So that sounds like we all have the potential. for extremism, but there must be some factors that are happening psychologically that prevent us from doing this all the time. Is that correct? So as Ari already indicated in his response, we believe that extremism is a biologically built-in mechanism that humans evolve to have in order to overcome situations of crises, situations where it's life or death and you're in the desert and you need water or you're being chased by a predator or or or enemies and in those situations you can't be distracted by other things you have to mobilize the entire repertoire of your resources and abilities to deal with the crisis and so when we think about extremism
这听起来我们每个人都有走向极端的潜能，但心理上一定有一些因素在阻止我们一直这样做。对吗？正如阿里在回答中已经指出的那样，我们认为极端主义是一种人类为了克服危机情况而进化出的生物内置机制，即在生死攸关的情况下，比如你在沙漠中需要水，或者你正被捕食者或敌人追赶，在这些情况下，你不能被其他事情分心，你必须调动所有的资源和能力来应对危机。所以当我们思考极端主义时，
outside of our primordial environments all it takes sometimes is to get a person into the mindset that this is life or death, that this is their existential need, you know. And it's, it's not so hard to do. We're pretty good at creating narratives that are convincing of that. And possibly in today's world, there are people who are especially adept at doing that. You know, we know about the evening news. They want to keep you on, but because they show you these shocking and horrible things. But also everyday exposure to news online is prioritizing things that are shocking, that are disturbing because it multiplies user engagement, which is what a lot of social media are after. So this mindset of survival and crisis that breeds extremism is not only limited to what
在原始环境之外，有时只需要让人进入一种“生死攸关”的心态，即这是他们的生存需求。这并不难做到。我们非常擅长创造令人信服的叙事。可能在当今世界，有些人特别擅长这样做。你知道，我们了解晚间新闻。他们想留住观众，因为他们展示了这些令人震惊和可怕的事情。但日常在线接触新闻也在优先考虑那些令人震惊、令人不安的事情，因为它能增加用户参与度，而这正是许多社交媒体所追求的。因此，这种滋生极端主义的生存和危机心态不仅限于极端主义最初的设计目的。
extremism was originally designed for. It's been co-opted and is very widely used today to harvest people's attention and to get them into this extremist mindset, whether it's buying things online or, you know, getting into some extremist communities online that have to do with eating in a particular way or like starving themselves or bodybuilding or indeed getting engaged with radical political ideas and actions. In the beginning of the book, you give examples of two people we might not think of together, but who both typify extremism in different ways. And I'm thinking of Gandhi and bin Laden. Can you tell us about that? What traits do these vastly dissimilar people share? I'm going to just briefly talk about it because Sophia is an expert on both.
它现在已被挪用，并被广泛用于获取人们的注意力，使他们进入这种极端主义心态，无论是网上购物，还是加入某些与特定饮食方式、节食、健美或参与激进政治思想和行动相关的极端主义社区。在书的开头，你们举了两个我们可能不会联想到一起的人的例子，但他们都以不同的方式代表了极端主义。我想到了甘地和本·拉登。能告诉我们吗？这两个截然不同的人有什么共同点？我只想简要谈谈，因为索菲亚是这两方面的专家。
But I think that what is common to them is this single-mindedness. and their readiness to sacrifice anything that falls outside the domain of that particular need. So in both cases, the underlying need was the quest for significance, for their nation, for their religion, and that justified a variety of practices that one would call extreme, rejection of all Western modes of doing things for Gandhi, the mobilization of people, believers, to fight the West, to fight and kill non-believers by Al-Qaeda. That single-mindedness, that one-track mind,
但我认为他们的共同点是这种一心一意，以及他们准备牺牲任何落入该特定需求领域之外的事物的意愿。在这两种情况下，潜在的需求都是对意义的追求，为了他们的国家，为了他们的宗教，这证明了各种被称为极端的做法是合理的，比如甘地拒绝所有西方的做事方式，基地组织动员信徒对抗西方，对抗并杀害非信徒。那种一心一意，那种只认准一个目标的思维，
readiness to sacrifice all on altar of that need was what common to both. But Sophia can add to that because she studied Gandhi and Osama extensively. So they also share some biographical information that is maybe strange to those of us who we know them as these giants in the political and historical landscape. So they both grew up in quite prominent and well-to-do families. They both were very shy when they were young, not known as leaders among their peers at all, kind of staying outside of the struggle for significance, at least in that moment. However, at a certain point in their late teens,
准备为那种需求牺牲一切，是他们两人的共同点。但索菲亚可以补充这一点，因为她深入研究了甘地和奥萨马。他们还分享了一些传记信息，对于我们这些视他们为政治和历史景观中的巨人的人来说，这可能很奇怪。他们都在相当显赫和富裕的家庭中长大。他们年轻时都很害羞，在同龄人中根本不是领导者，至少在那一刻，他们远离了对意义的争夺。然而，在他们十几岁末期，
they both became increasingly interested in what was essentially from both of them an anti-colonial struggle because they both grew up in countries that were dominated by a colonial power and felt that that was unjust and it needs to be addressed. And so both of them started first changing their diet, which is something we find across a lot of cases of extremism. That may be, you know, the first thing you notice about somebody is they change. he each other eat. For Osama bin Laden, that was that he'd begun fasting two days a week like the prophet, which for a teenage boy is a huge commitment. Fasting is like not eating at all,
他们都开始对本质上属于反殖民斗争的事情越来越感兴趣，因为他们都在被殖民大国统治的国家长大，并感到这是不公正的，需要解决。于是他们两人都开始改变饮食，这是我们在许多极端主义案例中发现的情况。这可能是你注意到某人改变的第一件事。对于奥萨马·本·拉登来说，他开始像先知一样每周禁食两天，对于一个十几岁的男孩来说，这是一个巨大的承诺。禁食就像完全不吃东西，
right, for two days a week. And he started doing it himself. And then he started pushing his family, his mother and his stepfather and his step-siblings to follow him on this path. For Gandhi, it was his vow to remain vegetarian, even though he was studying in lunch. He was, And in London, at that time, it was very difficult to be vegetarian and still eat in a way that he enjoyed. So really serious self-sacrifices in order to maintain and cultivate what they felt was important to them politically and as far as their identity was concerned. And then these sacrifices only grew greater. They started giving up the way they looked to others and as a result, they stood out with their dress. Gandhi gave up on the Western clothes.
每周两天。他开始自己这样做。然后他开始推动他的家人，他的母亲、继父和继兄弟姐妹跟随他走这条路。对于甘地来说，这是他保持素食的誓言，即使他当时正在伦敦学习。在当时的伦敦，要保持素食且吃得开心是非常困难的。所以，为了维持和培养他们认为在政治上和身份认同上重要的事情，他们确实做出了严重的自我牺牲。然后这些牺牲变得越来越大。他们开始放弃自己在他人眼中的形象，结果，他们的着装使他们脱颖而出。甘地放弃了西式服装。
Osama bin Laden started to wear traditional Muslim clothes and kind of felt the people who didn't do it were not right. Friends that were dressing in shorts, for example, to play soccer, were violating a moral boundary. And Osama bin Laden expressed it to his friends. So this dynamic process of, on the one hand, breaking social norms in order to cultivate a particular blueprint. belief. And on the other hand, with that breaking or straining social relationships, because that's what happens. When an extremist begins that extremist journey, other people feel the changes in them, and sometimes the extremist will express to them the desire that they follow them or change their own behaviors. That strains social relationships. So what happened in both Osama bin Laden's
奥萨马·本·拉登开始穿传统的穆斯林服装，并觉得不这样做的人是不对的。例如，穿短裤踢足球的朋友违反了道德界限。奥萨马·本·拉登向他的朋友表达了这一点。因此，这种一方面为了培养特定信仰而打破社会规范，另一方面又因这种打破而导致社会关系紧张的过程，就是所发生的事情。当一个极端分子开始那段极端主义旅程时，其他人会感受到他们的变化，有时极端分子会向他们表达希望他们跟随自己或改变行为的愿望。这会使社会关系紧张。所以奥萨马·本·拉登
and Gandhi's trajectory to becoming who they became as we knew them is some serious isolation. And for Gandhi, that was pivotal. So he was in South Africa about to travel on a train. He was already feeling as a discriminated minority being an Indian South Africa. And he had a first class ticket, but he was rejected from first class because he was an Indian. So given a choice of going to the second class or disembarking the train, he chose the latter. and he ended up spending a night on the platform all alone following this grave injustice. And that's when he came up with the idea of Satya Graha, which is the idea of peaceful, non-violent resistance that then became the signature
和甘地在成为我们所熟知的他们这一轨迹中，发生了一些严重的孤立。对于甘地来说，这是关键。当时他在南非，正准备乘火车旅行。他已经感到作为印度裔南非人受到歧视。他有一张头等舱车票，但因为他是印度人而被拒绝进入头等舱。在选择去二等舱还是下车之间，他选择了后者。在经历了这种严重的不公正之后，他独自一人在站台上度过了一夜。就在那时，他想出了“萨提亚格拉哈”（Satya Graha）的想法，即和平、非暴力的抵抗，这后来成为了他一生和追随他的运动的标志。
of his life and the movement that followed him. For Osama bin Laden, the isolation was the result of his increased radicalization and his growing conflict with governments, including his own government, the Saudi government, and him becoming a persona non grata and somebody who was hunted internationally. And the isolation and secrecy that that kind of life entailed also brought him into seclusion.
对于奥萨马·本·拉登来说，孤立是他日益激进化的结果，也是他与包括他本国政府（沙特政府）在内的政府之间冲突加剧的结果，他成为了不受欢迎的人，并受到国际通缉。这种生活所带来的孤立和秘密也使他陷入了隐居。
And that's another hallmark of an extremist's journey that at some point they end up quite isolated. And the only people who can stand their... their demands on their extremism, are other extremists. And that very often, like it was for Gandhi, is the kind of moment that pushes them ultimate lifestyle and choice that defines their extremist and themselves. I wanted to add something to that,
这也是极端分子旅程的另一个标志，即在某个时刻，他们最终会变得相当孤立。而唯一能忍受他们对极端主义要求的人，就是其他极端分子。这通常就像甘地那样，是推动他们最终走向定义其极端主义和他们自己的生活方式和选择的时刻。我想补充一点，
and that is that there is many more followers and imitators of Osama bin Laden than there are of Gandhi, and there is a good reason for it. in the sense that the violent way of attaining significance through aggression, through dominance, through the glory of the militancy, is a very primordial way of attaining significance, whereas the more passive resistance that Gandhi advocated is much less direct assertion of your power,
那就是奥萨马·本·拉登的追随者和模仿者比甘地的要多得多，这是有充分理由的。从某种意义上说，通过侵略、统治、武装斗争的荣耀来获得意义的暴力方式，是一种非常原始的获得意义的方式，而甘地所倡导的更被动的抵抗，则远非对他人的直接权力主张，
of your dominance, of your metering. So I think that's one difference between these two, who share many commonalities. And one commonality that Sophia didn't mention is that both of them were assassinated for their ideology. You describe personality traits that sound very much like fixations of the type that you might see in somebody who has maybe autism spectrum disorder or obsessive compulsive disorder. And I'm just wondering whether extremism is related to these kinds of mental health disorders. So I don't know that I would put it that way, that, you know, most people who are exhibiting extremist tendencies are not diagnosable as having any kind of mental health issues. And in fact,
对你的统治，对你的重要性的主张。所以我认为这是这两个人之间的一个区别，尽管他们有很多共同点。索菲亚没有提到的一个共同点是，他们两人都因为自己的意识形态而被暗杀。你描述的性格特征听起来非常像你在患有自闭症谱系障碍或强迫症的人身上可能看到的固执。我只是想知道极端主义是否与这些心理健康障碍有关。我不知道我会那样说，因为大多数表现出极端主义倾向的人并不能被诊断为患有任何心理健康问题。事实上，
as we started saying, extremism is in everybody's repertoire and under the right conditions, everybody will probably act in an extreme way. So in that sense, it's a normative possibility to be extreme. However, mental illness often looks very much like extremism in the singular obsession with something. So for anorexics, it's the obsession with losing weight and restraining their calorie intake. For people who have obsessive-compulsive disorder, it's whatever the fear is, maybe it's the fear of germs or fear of being trampled that becomes the singular obsession that ends up defining much of their day-to-day lives and their behaviors. Some forms of depression, they have this feature of rumination
正如我们开始说的那样，极端主义在每个人的能力范围内，在适当的条件下，每个人都可能会采取极端行为。从这个意义上说，变得极端是一种规范的可能性。然而，心理疾病在对某件事的单一痴迷方面，往往看起来非常像极端主义。对于厌食症患者来说，是对减肥和限制卡路里摄入的痴迷。对于患有强迫症的人来说，无论恐惧是什么，也许是对细菌的恐惧，或者是对被践踏的恐惧，都变成了定义他们大部分日常生活的单一痴迷和行为。某些形式的抑郁症具有反刍的特征，
where a person spends much of their time just thinking back about all the failures that they've experienced and all the things that they think are wrong with them and rejections and so on. And this circular, endless loop of negative thought ends up consuming them to the degree that it becomes a mental health issue. So mental disorders are disordered ways of thinking, of feeling, of behaving that can look very much like extremism, which at some points can be very normative. So, yeah, again, you know, the manifestation has this common element of fixating on one thing
一个人大部分时间都在回想他们经历过的所有失败，以及他们认为自己身上所有错误的事情、拒绝等等。这种循环的、无休止的负面思维循环最终消耗了他们，以至于它变成了一个心理健康问题。因此，精神障碍是思维、感觉、行为的紊乱方式，看起来非常像极端主义，而极端主义在某些时候可能是非常规范的。所以，是的，再次强调，这种表现形式有一个共同的元素，即固执于一件事，
to the exclusion of other things. The etiology could be different. For example, in the case of autism, it's unclear that what is happening is suppression of other things or simply those other things not being particularly well developed like social sensitivity and social awareness.
而排斥其他事情。病因可能不同。例如，在自闭症的情况下，不清楚发生的是对其他事物的抑制，还是仅仅是那些其他事物（如社会敏感性和社会意识）没有得到特别好的发展。
So it may look similarly on the surface and yet have different underlying etiology. It's a fascinating possibility to look at the commonalities and how far, how deeply they go into the psychological process. And that's something that future generations of researchers hopefully will pursue. You thought this was your run club era. Turns out it was more of a thinking about run club era. The good news?
所以它在表面上看起来可能相似，但却有不同的潜在病因。审视这些共同点以及它们在心理过程中深入到什么程度，是一个迷人的可能性。希望未来几代研究人员能继续探索。你以为这是你的跑步俱乐部时代。结果发现这更多是“思考跑步俱乐部”的时代。好消息？
Someone's marathon training is about to start. Sell your workout gear on Deepop. Just snap a few photos and we'll take care the rest. They get their race day fit and you get a payout for trying. Someone on Deepop wants what you've got. Start selling now. Deepop where taste recognizes taste. Is it just my impression or is the world becoming more extremist? Do we go through cycles in history where there are times when things are more extreme and less extreme? I think that the world is becoming more extreme, to some extent, driven by the technology of social media and the internet.
有人要开始马拉松训练了。在Deepop上卖掉你的运动装备吧。只需拍几张照片，剩下的交给我们。他们能得到比赛日的装备，而你也能因为尝试过而获得报酬。Deepop上有人想要你拥有的东西。现在就开始卖吧。Deepop，品味识别品味的地方。是我的错觉，还是世界正变得越来越极端？我们在历史上是否会经历周期，即在某些时期事情更极端，而在某些时期不那么极端？我认为世界正在变得越来越极端，在某种程度上，这是由社交媒体和互联网技术驱动的。
You know, the clamor, the competition for attention, the competition for being popular and acceptable drives this idea of standing out, mattering, being somebody to huge extremes. I just read a story yesterday in Washington Post about a ski jumper who jumped to his death in order to attain the glory of doing something that would make his video viral. And so that kind of competition for attention that is propagated by the social media is instilling proclivity to go to the extremes in order to stand out, in order to matter, in order to have significance, we have the attention of other people. Sophia, you want to add to that?
你知道，对注意力的喧嚣、竞争，对受欢迎和被接受的竞争，推动了这种脱颖而出、变得重要、成为某人的想法，走向了巨大的极端。我昨天刚在《华盛顿邮报》上读到一个故事，关于一名跳台滑雪运动员跳向死亡，以获得做某事能让他的视频疯传的荣耀。因此，社交媒体传播的这种对注意力的竞争，正在灌输一种走向极端的倾向，以便脱颖而出，以便变得重要，以便拥有意义，我们拥有其他人的注意力。索菲亚，你想补充吗？
Yeah, it's my impression, too, that the world is becoming more extreme. I think that the social media are a huge problem in that sense. As Ari said, because one of the mechanisms to cultivate extremism, as we described in the book, is what in psychology is known as mere exposure. So this is a very well-known psychological phenomenon that a person who goes on his morning run, if that person sees an observer casually looking over, they will run faster. So they will expand more energy. They will become a little more extreme in whatever it is that they're doing.
是的，我的印象也是世界正在变得越来越极端。我认为社交媒体在这方面是一个巨大的问题。正如阿里所说，因为正如我们在书中描述的那样，培养极端主义的机制之一是心理学中所谓的“单纯曝光效应”。这是一个非常著名的心理学现象，一个去晨跑的人，如果那个人看到一个观察者随意地看过来，他们会跑得更快。所以他们会消耗更多的能量。无论他们在做什么，他们都会变得稍微极端一点。
So this idea that you're being judged by others is a natural ingredient that helps extremism thrive. And if before we were judged by our friends and neighbors, now it seems like the whole world is looking when we're posting or comments. commenting or liking. So we're on the stage and not in a good way, you know, and that makes extremism grow. But also another thing that is relevant here is COVID, which was an existential crisis, especially in the beginning when we didn't know much about the virus. It looked horrible. And as I already said, crisis is one thing for which extremism is built. And so around the world, we saw huge political changes take place after COVID, including protests.
所以这种你被他人评判的想法是一个自然的成分，有助于极端主义的滋生。如果以前我们是被朋友和邻居评判，现在当我们发帖、评论或点赞时，似乎全世界都在看着。所以我们站在舞台上，而且不是以一种好的方式，你知道，这让极端主义增长。但这里相关的另一件事是新冠疫情，这是一场生存危机，特别是在我们对病毒知之甚少的时候。它看起来很可怕。正如我之前所说，危机是极端主义建立的基础之一。因此，在世界各地，我们看到新冠疫情后发生了巨大的政治变化，包括抗议活动。
We had Black Lives Matter protests here, and then we had the January 6th protests, and we had populist movements come into power in a lot of countries. We've all become a little more extreme, and I think we're still going through it from where I'm sitting. Do political extremists tend to fall on one side of, the spectrum or the other, or are they evenly distributed? I would say that they can be evenly distributed. We have had waves of left-wing extremism culminating in communism that took over large portions of the world, and of course had fascism and Nazism that also threatened the security and stability
我们这里有“黑人的命也是命”抗议活动，然后是1月6日的抗议活动，许多国家出现了民粹主义运动。我们都变得稍微极端了一些，我认为从我的角度来看，我们仍在经历这个过程。政治极端分子倾向于落在光谱的一边还是另一边，还是他们分布均匀？我会说他们可以分布均匀。我们经历过左翼极端主义的浪潮，最终导致了占领世界大部分地区的共产主义，当然还有威胁地球安全和稳定的法西斯主义和纳粹主义。
of the planet. Now we have right-wing, rising, nationalism, rising, religious extremism. So the ideologies, the narratives that can serve extremism can vary in content. The important thing is that they are presented as something that serves this all-important need to matter, to be significant. Who creates these narratives? Does the leading extremist sort of start the ball rolling? And it sounds like there is a level of contagion, social contagion going on here. Am I getting that right?
现在我们有右翼、崛起的民族主义、崛起的宗教极端主义。所以，能够服务于极端主义的意识形态、叙事在内容上可能会有所不同。重要的是，它们被呈现为服务于这种至关重要的“变得重要、具有意义”的需求。谁创造了这些叙事？是主要的极端分子开启了这一切吗？听起来这里有一种传染，社会传染正在发生。我理解对了吗？
It's an interesting question that I've been asked a lot with respect to Q&O in particular, which was on the front pages of newspapers in this country for a few years, and I've studied it some. And a lot of people were interested in who's behind it. And in fact, there were a couple of documentaries that were done by HBO and some other authoritative resources. but I think it's less interesting who creates it. And one reason is that none of these narratives are new. So with respect to QAnon, every single conspiracy theory that is embraced by Q&N
这是一个有趣的问题，关于“匿名者Q”（QAnon），我被问过很多次，它几年来一直占据着这个国家报纸的头版，我也研究过它。很多人对谁在背后操纵它很感兴趣。事实上，HBO和其他一些权威资源制作了几部纪录片。但我认为谁创造了它并不那么有趣。原因之一是这些叙事都不是新的。关于“匿名者Q”，每一个被“匿名者Q”所拥抱的阴谋论，
has been around for decades, if not sometimes, sensualies or millennia, whether it's blood libel, people drinking blood of children, or it's flat earth, or it's, you know, human lizard hybrids who were going to take over the world. All of those we've known, they've been around. It's like viruses are in the air all the time.
都已经存在了几十年，如果不是几个世纪或几千年的话，无论是血祭诽谤（人们喝儿童的血），还是地平说，或者是那些要接管世界的蜥蜴人混血儿。所有这些我们都知道，它们一直存在。就像病毒一直存在于空气中一样。
And it's only when the immune system is weakened or compromised that would become susceptible to these viral stories and allow them to colonize and threaten our society. And in fact, if you look through the history at the time when these... conspiratorial narratives became dangerous and deadly and resulted in a huge number of deaths, like, for example, the witch hunts did, or like, for example, the protocols of the elders of Zion did. Each of those resulted in thousands, if not tens of thousands of people being killed or
只有当免疫系统减弱或受损时，我们才会对这些病毒式的故事变得易感，并允许它们殖民和威胁我们的社会。事实上，如果你回顾历史，在这些阴谋论叙事变得危险和致命并导致大量死亡的时候，比如猎巫行动，或者比如《锡安长老会纪要》。每一个都导致了成千上万，甚至数万人被杀或
tortured or otherwise really, you know, treated horribly for no good reason at all. In both of those cases, the narratives have long predated their rise to the surface as this major phenomenon. And in both of those cases, they were very quickly discovered to be a fraud. It was known at the time of which Hunts, that the book was a fraud. It was known at the time of Protocols of the Elders of Zion that the book was a fraud. It was known at the time of Hew andon that it was a completely debunked, conspiracy theory. And then doesn't stop it from spreading and it doesn't stop it from affecting people and it doesn't stop them from engaging in extreme behaviors like spending days and nights
被折磨，或者以其他方式被极其糟糕地对待，而没有任何正当理由。在这两种情况下，叙事在它们作为这种重大现象浮出水面之前很久就已经存在了。在这两种情况下，它们很快就被发现是欺诈。在猎巫行动时，人们就知道那本书是欺诈。在《锡安长老会纪要》时，人们就知道那本书是欺诈。在“匿名者Q”时，人们就知道它是一个完全被揭穿的阴谋论。但这并不能阻止它传播，不能阻止它影响人们，也不能阻止他们从事极端行为，比如没日没夜地
online in these rabbit holes of conspiracy theories and neglecting their own families and in fact breaking up relationships with their siblings, with their spouses, their children over these beliefs. And in some really extreme cases, people will kill their children. We've had these incidents happen where they believe that the children are human lizard hybrids, or they believe that the children are destined for the cabal, and so it's better that they be murdered at the hand of their mother. Right. So the ideology itself is just kind of a veneer on the real problem,
沉迷于这些阴谋论的兔子洞，忽视自己的家庭，甚至因为这些信仰而与兄弟姐妹、配偶、孩子断绝关系。在一些非常极端的案例中，人们会杀死自己的孩子。我们发生过这样的事件，他们相信孩子是蜥蜴人混血儿，或者他们相信孩子注定要属于阴谋集团，所以最好死在母亲手中。对。所以意识形态本身只是真正问题的一层外衣，
which is that people feel that they're living in a time of crisis, and that their existence is threatened. And unless they do something extreme, all will be lost, which is what is a common thread among all of these different historical cases. So, you know, they say that the professional psychology is desperately trying to catch with common sense. And, you know, there is a sense in which people know psychology. They know the vulnerabilities. They know the threats.
那就是人们觉得他们生活在一个危机时代，他们的生存受到威胁。除非他们采取极端行动，否则一切都将失去，这是所有这些不同历史案例中的共同点。所以，你知道，人们说专业心理学正在拼命追赶常识。而且，你知道，人们在某种意义上了解心理学。他们了解弱点。他们了解威胁。
They know how to push people's buttons and what kind of story to tell them to mobilize them to extreme actions. Stories about, you know, children being killed, women being raped, things that threaten you masculinity and mobilize you to action. These things are known. We know it from our own psychology,
他们知道如何触动人们的痛点，知道讲什么样的故事来动员他们采取极端行动。关于孩子被杀、妇女被强奸的故事，那些威胁你男子气概并动员你采取行动的事情。这些事情是众所周知的。我们从我们自己的心理学中知道这一点，
from the psychology of our children, our friends, and, you know, people who want to write to power or want to exert influence, are using it in creative ways, capitalizing on stories and themes that existed for centuries in order to capture the moment, the point of vulnerability, and the MS power, MS influence, and most votes ascend to political stations and so forth. for our listeners who might be concerned that either they themselves or someone they know is tending toward extremism, first of all, how do you know that you're reaching a danger point and what can you do to pull yourself away? One red flag that is actually often described as such by people in the prevention of violent crime community
从我们孩子、朋友的心理学中知道这一点，而且，你知道，那些想要掌握权力或想要施加影响的人，正在以创造性的方式利用它，利用几个世纪以来就存在的叙事和主题，以抓住时机、抓住脆弱点，并获得权力、获得影响、获得选票、登上政治职位等等。对于那些可能担心自己或认识的人正倾向于极端主义的听众，首先，你怎么知道你正在达到危险点，你能做些什么来让自己远离？一个红旗信号，实际上经常被暴力犯罪预防社区的人描述为这样，
is when the person starts pulling away from their social circles, when they all of a sudden stop going to meetings with people that they used to regularly see, when they end up spending more and more time alone, or completely changed their social circle. So this social disconnect, as we've discussed before, is often a whole mark of increasing extremism because the person has already done,
就是当一个人开始远离他们的社交圈时，当他们突然停止参加他们过去经常见的人的聚会时，当他们最终花越来越多的时间独处，或者完全改变了他们的社交圈时。所以这种社会脱节，正如我们之前讨论的那样，通常是极端主义加剧的标志，因为这个人已经做了
or said something that alerted people in their circle that caused them to talk to the person or expressed their disagreement with the extremist position, causing a rift or a strain on their relationship. So when this isolation or a change of social milieu is in place, this is a hallmark of abutting extremism. So if your loved one is exhibiting something like that, then the best thing to do is, is to try to stay around. Instead of arguing with them,
或说了什么引起了他们圈子里的人的警觉，导致他们与那个人交谈或表达了对极端主义立场的不赞同，从而导致了裂痕或关系紧张。所以当这种孤立或社会环境的改变出现时，这就是极端主义临近的标志。所以如果你的亲人表现出类似的情况，那么最好的做法是尝试留在他们身边。而不是与他们争论，
which is the natural thing to do, instead of trying to disabuse them of what you think are their mistaken motions, try to be there for them on just a human level, not on the level of discussing politics or whatever extremism the person is leaning into, but trying to understand their feelings. What is it that makes them feel
这是自然而然会做的事情，而不是试图纠正你认为他们错误的观念，尝试在人类层面上陪伴他们，而不是在讨论政治或那个人倾向于的任何极端主义的层面上，而是尝试理解他们的感受。是什么让他们感到
that they're living in a crisis? What is it that makes them be willing to break social connections, be willing to sacrifice things, and support them in a way that is genuine and kind and constant, which from research we know is the best bet to get a person out of extremist situations at a moment when they're ready to do so. I wanted to add a couple of comments. First of all, we must remember that extreme is not necessarily a negative thing. Some of the greatest contributions to science, to art,
他们生活在危机中？是什么让他们愿意打破社会联系，愿意牺牲事物，并以一种真诚、善良和持续的方式支持他们，我们从研究中知道，这是在一个人准备好时，让他们摆脱极端主义情况的最佳选择。我想补充几点评论。首先，我们必须记住，极端并不一定是一件负面的事情。一些对科学、艺术、
to political philosophy, to world peace, were contributed by people who are extremists. Martin Luther King used to refer to himself as a radical. So, you know, this focused commitment to a cause can be in a service of good things, of pro-social things, things that construct rather than distract, However, we also know that extremists takes a toll on the extremists. We recently carried out, our team carried out research on 70 nations, and the one robust
政治哲学、世界和平的最伟大贡献，都是由极端分子做出的。马丁·路德·金过去常称自己为激进分子。所以，你知道，这种对事业的专注承诺可以服务于好的事情，服务于亲社会的事情，服务于建设而非破坏的事情。然而，我们也知道，极端主义对极端分子本身是有代价的。我们最近进行了研究，我们的团队对70个国家进行了研究，一个稳健的
finding is that extremism is negatively related to well-being. It takes a price. The fact that you suppress your needs, suppress your social needs, suppress your family connections, suppress your relatedness. takes its stall. And at the end of the day, the extremists are not happy campers. They suffer a lot. So that has to be taken into consideration.
发现是极端主义与幸福感呈负相关。它是有代价的。你压抑自己的需求、压抑社会需求、压抑家庭联系、压抑相关性的事实，会让你付出代价。归根结底，极端分子并不是快乐的人。他们遭受了很多痛苦。所以这必须被考虑在内。
And I think that the third thing is that psychological literacy, understanding yourself, understanding, reading our book, if I may suggest that, Sophia is supporting me in that recommendation. Yes. Understanding your own psyche, understanding when too much is too much and what you are actually
我认为第三点是心理素养，了解自己，了解自己，阅读我们的书（如果我可以建议的话），索菲亚支持我的这个建议。是的。了解你自己的心理，了解什么时候“太多了”以及你实际上
doing in excluding everything else for this one crazy commitment, that can give you pause and allow you to navigate to regulate your life in a more judicious, thoughtful way. So how
在为了这个疯狂的承诺而排斥其他一切时在做什么，这可以让你停下来，让你以一种更明智、更深思熟虑的方式来调节你的生活。那么你们
did you each get interested in studying this syndrome, this situation? We both come from the study of terror And for me, the bulb was the time where the term terrorism was replaced by the term violent extremism. And Sophia knows the background to that change. I thought it's political correctness, but it's more than that.
是如何对研究这种综合征、这种情况产生兴趣的？我们都来自恐怖主义研究。对我来说，这个领域是“恐怖主义”一词被“暴力极端主义”一词所取代的时期。索菲亚知道这种变化的背景。我以为这是政治正确，但它不仅仅是那样。
And when I pondered the term violent extremism, I realized that maybe there are other extremism that are not violent. diet, extreme sports, extreme love crashes, all kinds of behavioral and substance addictions. These are all forms of extremism. And I pondered whether there could be a common psychological core to those various extremism. And that's when we started talking about the possibility of this motivational imbalance when one need overrides everything else. Yes. So we both study terrorism, but I had, although I didn't yet think of it in terms of extremism, it was very clear to me that some of the greatest visionaries that our civilization is built around, including Jesus, right? They are extremists in fundamental ways, even if they reject violence and lie terrorists. Understanding the complete commitment that terrorists have helped me to understand self-sacrifice of,
当我思考“暴力极端主义”这个词时，我意识到也许还有其他不暴力的极端主义。饮食、极限运动、极端的爱情迷恋，各种行为和物质成瘾。这些都是极端主义的形式。我思考这些各种极端主义是否可能有一个共同的心理核心。就在那时，我们开始谈论这种动机失衡的可能性，即一种需求压倒了一切。是的。所以我们都研究恐怖主义，但我虽然还没有从极端主义的角度来思考它，但我非常清楚，我们文明建立在其周围的一些最伟大的远见卓识者，包括耶稣，对吧？他们在根本上是极端分子，即使他们拒绝暴力和恐怖主义。理解恐怖分子所拥有的完全承诺，帮助我理解了
of people who have done fantastic things that were all grateful for. I mean, we enjoy, you know, rights and freedoms and technology and advances in medicine that were carried out by people who gave their all. People tested vaccines on themselves in the olden days, you know, and a lot of doctors died as a result or suffered horrible consequences by doing this extreme self-sacrifice in the name of medicine. or Maria Kiri's extreme self-sacrifice in the name of her science. I just want to be clear of something that we clarify in the book,
那些做出了我们都感激的奇妙事情的人的自我牺牲。我的意思是，我们享受权利、自由、技术以及医学进步，这些都是由那些付出了一切的人实现的。在过去，人们在自己身上测试疫苗，你知道，许多医生因此死亡或因这种以医学名义进行的极端自我牺牲而遭受了可怕的后果。或者玛丽·居里以科学名义进行的极端自我牺牲。我只是想澄清我们在书中澄清的一件事，
but for the listeners too, that we don't believe, and we have examples in the book to support this, that it takes extremism to achieve great things. We don't believe that you must lay your life on the altar of science to advance it, or that nothing worth doing was ever done without huge personal sacrifice. There are plenty of examples, including Einstein and others who lead, you know, Picasso, quite balanced lives, combining their deep, profound passion for either art or technology or science, whatever, with other interests, be playing the violin or traveling the world or
但对于听众来说，我们不相信（我们书中有例子支持这一点），实现伟大的事情需要极端主义。我们不相信你必须把生命放在科学的祭坛上才能推进它，或者没有巨大的个人牺牲就做不成任何值得做的事情。有很多例子，包括爱因斯坦和其他人，他们过着相当平衡的生活，将他们对艺术、技术或科学的深厚热情与其他兴趣结合起来，无论是拉小提琴、环游世界还是
engaging with colleagues and friends and women. So it's not that extremism is a necessary component for our world to thrive, for our science to advance, for the human rights to flourish. It does sometimes help, but more often than not, it hurts, and it particularly hurts the people who engage in it. So last question, I'd like to ask this one of most of the people I talk to. What are you working on now? What's next, either in this area or other areas where you are conducting research?
与同事、朋友和女性交往。所以，极端主义并不是我们世界繁荣、科学进步、人权蓬勃发展的必要组成部分。它有时会有所帮助，但更多时候它是有害的，而且它特别伤害那些参与其中的人。所以最后一个问题，我想问我交谈过的大多数人。你们现在在做什么？接下来是什么，无论是在这个领域还是你们正在进行研究的其他领域？
We have a contract for a new book, and that book is going to be titled, To Matter to Marvel. And this attempts to juxtapose this human quest for significance and metering with the opposite psychology of admiring. of belittling oneself in vis-à-vis nature, vis-a-vis greater forces, vis-à-vis God, vis-a-vis some great heroes. And the balance between these two that, again, to us, represents the most healthy way of leading one's life, not being committed to greatness, to an excessive attempt,
我们有一份新书的合同，那本书的标题将是《重要与惊叹》（To Matter to Marvel）。这试图将人类对意义和重要性的追求与相反的“赞叹”心理并列。在自然面前、在更伟大的力量面前、在上帝面前、在一些伟大的英雄面前贬低自己。这两者之间的平衡，对我们来说，代表了过上健康生活的最健康方式，不是致力于伟大，不是过度尝试，
and not belittling oneself to the point of losing agency, losing a sense of self, but being able to be small and be big, to be and not to be, so to speak. So moving from extremism to moderation, is that what you're saying? To some extent, yes. Would you like to add, Sophia?
也不是贬低自己到失去能动性、失去自我感的程度，而是能够变得渺小又变得伟大，存在又不存在，可以这么说。所以从极端主义转向中庸，这就是你所说的吗？在某种程度上，是的。你想补充吗，索菲亚？
I think we have the need, maybe not an extreme need, but we all have a need to have something greater than ourselves that we can bow to in our daily lives. It can be science for scientists or it can be God for people of religion or it can be nature. And we also have the need to matter and to be significant. And when there is this deep imbalance is when we get extremism.
我认为我们有这种需求，也许不是极端的需求，但我们每个人都需要在日常生活中有一种超越自我的东西可以去敬畏。对于科学家来说，这可以是科学；对于宗教人士来说，这可以是上帝；或者也可以是大自然。我们同时也需要感到自己很重要、有意义。而当这种深层的不平衡出现时，极端主义就会产生。
And finding threading the needle, finding that equanimity, satisfying both needs for being big and being small, is what we think is a good life. Well, I want to thank you both for joining me. This has been a very fascinating conversation. Thank you for having us. Thank you for having us. It was delightful.
在两者之间找到平衡，找到那种宁静，既满足自己渺小的需求，又满足自己伟大的需求，这就是我们认为的美好生活。好的，非常感谢两位今天能来参加节目。这是一次非常引人入胜的谈话。谢谢你邀请我们。谢谢你邀请我们。这真是太愉快了。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please follow us and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association.
您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何您收听播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》往期节目。如果您喜欢我们的内容，请关注我们并留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Winerman 制作。感谢您收听美国心理学会的节目。
I'm Kim Mills. Ryan Reynolds here from Mint Mobile, with a message for everyone paying big wireless way too much. Please, for the love of everything good in this world, stop. With Mint, you can get premium wireless for just $15 a month. Of course, if you enjoy overpaying, no judgments, but that's weird. Okay, one judgment. Anyway, give it a try at mintmobile.com slash switch. Upfront payment of $45 for three-month plan, equivalent to $15 per month required.
我是 Kim Mills。我是来自 Mint Mobile 的 Ryan Reynolds，给所有在无线通信上花费过高的人带个口信。求求你们，为了这世上一切美好的事物，停下来吧。使用 Mint，您每月只需 15 美元即可获得优质的无线服务。当然，如果您喜欢多付钱，我不会评判，但这很奇怪。好吧，我确实评判了。总之，请访问 mintmobile.com/switch 试一试。需要预付 45 美元购买三个月的套餐，相当于每月 15 美元。
Intro rate first three months only, then full price plan options available. Taxes and fees extra. See full terms at mintmobile.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
入门费率仅限前三个月，之后可选择全价套餐。税费另计。完整条款请见 mintmobile.com。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。